I am leaving in a week I just hope they
don't hate me it's raining
I'm leaving in five minutes Janelle and
her kids are on one side and Robin and
Cody are on the other
hi Christine good luck bye thank you
I don't want to see Christine ever again
Cody Brown's ready to say goodbye to
Christine for good it's very difficult
emotionally while the episodes are
airing it's all very raw again on top of
that the brown patriarch's other
marriages are falling apart he still has
marriages with us and he still has to
fix them or he's going to ruin every
single one of them it all goes down in
the Sister Wives mid-season trailer as
Christine plans to move away from
Arizona the rest of the family is kinda
mad about it congratulations you're
leaving the family like I don't know
what I'm supposed to say to this you are
running away rather than being
accountable
you're like I'm divorced
I'm leaving
I'm done with you she did this
thanks honey
I'm feeling betrayed I can't imagine
what Cody's spelling I'm trying to be a
husband a father to their children a
lover to two people who may not see eye
to eye that's a real Challenge and to
challenge Cody's now facing tension with
Janelle you and I have been acting like
we weren't a married couple for most of
our marriage Chanel
everything seems to be going bad here if
he can't handle my Independence I'd
works for me anymore
could you I'm mad as hell because you
know what everybody put this on me
would you ever have any empathy for me
when you're in pain I try to understand
you Janelle this is a really bad idea
for you to walk off on this one but his
relationship with Janelle is not the
only one on the Rocks I don't really
consider myself married to Mary if she
wanted to move on and marry another she
wouldn't get an argument with me Cody's
feelings don't exactly come as a
surprise he previously told Mary he
supports her leaving the reason I'm
suggesting this to Mary is is honestly
as a family anymore it doesn't feel like
we actually interact that much at this
point I just I don't know what to do I
am lost I was with all relationships you
know whether it's spouses or friends or
family or Sisters You've Got the ups and
downs you just do and it's just a matter
of what your commitment level is and his
fans wait to see how those relationships
play out Christine told E.T last week
where her relationship currently stands
with the other wives right now I'm
requiring a bit of a distance to be
honest with you I feel like I'm just
starting to get to know me and I really
like me so for right now everything's
just gonna stay as is with all of the
relationships you know we're not going
to get any closer at all I'm super close
with Chanel that's of course very
different Janelle and I are to probably
just continue I don't know if you can be
Sister Wives you know if you're not
really but I just consider tell my
sister if she just always will be
[Music]